all the reasons in the world and I've
read your book you have the 10 you know
all these key success Etc would you say
is the number one reason why people fail
not necessarily why they make it the
complete opposite lack of brains lack of
effort lack of brain's lack of effort
yeah they just they don't do the work
they don't learn you know when you walk
in the room when you start a business
and you start to talk about somebody
you're never in a vacuum with no
competition you know unless you're just
extremely lucky and if there's going to
be competition that means somebody else
knows your business as well as you do
when you get started and if you walk
into a competitive environment and they
still know more about the business than
you do and more about your customers
you're going to lose